[Música]
hoy ecuador elige presidente de las
últimas encuestas las dan la ventaja a
andrés hará uso respaldado por el ex
presidente de izquierda rafael correa
el banquero guillermo lasso lo sigue
pero todo apunta a que podría ser
necesaria una segunda vuelta en la
carrera por reemplazar a lenin moreno
emergencia en el norte de la india por
una avalancha consecuencia de la ruptura
de un glaciar del himalaya que chocó
contra una presa toneladas de agua y
barro cayeron sobre poblaciones
montañosas y hay al menos 150
desaparecidos y 3 fallecidos las
autoridades se movilizan para atender la
emergencia
y miles de personas salieron de nuevo a
las calles este domingo en mianmar en
protesta por el golpe de estado-militar
la junta restableció al menos
temporalmente el servicio de internet
que estuvo bloqueado por más de 24 horas
mientras los ciudadanos reclaman
democracia y la liberación de aung san
suu kyi
regresamos con ustedes para actualizar
la información internacional en francia
24 iniciamos el informativo en noticias
de américa latina'
hoy los ecuatorianos eligen a su nuevo
presidente y vice presidente de entre 16
formulas andrés araúxo apadrinado por
rafael correa- guillermo lasso quien
apoya el libre mercado y ya a cooper es
candidato indígena son los favoritos a
ocupar la presidencia ecuatoriana un
mandato que llega en uno de los momentos
más difíciles para el país andino la
polarización política se agrava con una
devastada economía un sistema de salud
precario y la comunidad indígena
sensible a paralizar el país en
cualquier momento luís muñoz o nos
entregan un recuento de los retos que
afrontará el nuevo presidente
el mandato de lenin moreno es un buen
ejemplo el próximo presidente de ecuador
no lo va a tener fácil en primer lugar
tendrá que lidiar con una sociedad
polarizada y un debate público centrado
en dos palabras constantes correa y
venezuela hugo por un andrew zarautz
candidato apadrinado por el ex
presidente ecuatoriano genera esperanzas
en sectores de la población que rechazan
la austeridad y reivindican un mayor
papel social del estado
del otro lado detractores de rafael
correa consideran que volver al
socialismo llevaría al país a
convertirse en venezuela
este debate no se puede entender sin la
maltrecha economía ecuatoriana desde
2015 el país vive la desaceleración
económica por la caída de los precios
del petróleo una dependencia a la que se
le suma a una pandemia que deja 600.000
desempleados una economía contraída
entre un 10 y un 12 por ciento una deuda
que equivale al 60 por ciento del
producto interior bruto y una tasa de
pobreza en torno al 35 por ciento en
nuevo presidente además se encontrará
con una reestructuración del pago de la
deuda de 17
millones de dólares sin embargo tendrá
que decidir si acepta las contundentes
exigencias de austeridad del fondo
monetario internacional o si decide
enfrentarlas pero en lo que sigue
coinciden todos es en la necesidad de
empezar una campaña de vacunación que
vuelva a poner en marcha la economía en
un sistema de salud precario que se vio
superado en la primera ola de kobe 19 en
guayaquil segunda ciudad de ecuador el
nuevo presidente también tendrá que
lidiar con un organizado movimiento
indígena en 2019 ya demostró a lenin
moreno su capacidad para paralizar el
país por último la elección será clave
en un plano internacional
una victoria de arauz acercaría a
ecuador a bolivia argentina y podría
reactivar unasur mientras que también
por otro lado podría debilitar la
recuperada relación con eeuu
nos acompaña desde quito sofía cordero
ella es politóloga docente del instituto
de altos estudios nacionales e
integrante de la red de politólogos de
ecuador gracias a ustedes por
acompañarnos buenos días y veíamos en el
informe los retos que le esperan al
nuevo presidente de ecuador sin duda la
economía y la gestión de la pandemia son
una gran preocupación cuál es el camino
que a su juicio debería tomar quien
llegue a la jefatura de estado para
mitigar está castigada de economía
ecuatoriana
buenos días si digamos que el principal
reto al que se enfrente se enfrentaría
el presidente electo es justamente
empezar una campaña de vacunación no en
esta economía tan deprimida y de eso
dependerá digamos yo creo que el triunfo
el éxito por lo menos en los primeros
100 días de gobierno por decir algo
y luego las medidas económicas para
salir de esta grave crisis no tenemos
dos opciones o digamos tres opciones o
tres modelos que se han planteado el
retorno al correísmo una nueva derecha
que no ha estado en el poder y la opción
del movimiento indígena que vuelve para
cuestionarla la izquierda conservadora
no que representa el correísmo con
nuevas propuestas para salir de la
crisis
bueno hablemos hoy precisamente de eso
otro de los puntos en la mira es el ex
presidente rafael correa que apoyó al
candidato araus que le espera ecuador si
vuelve a la senda de correa
bueno le espera un retorno bastante
complejo no un ambiente de venganza que
es la que es el tinte no del correísmo
una venganza de todo lo que en el
gobierno de lenin moreno se avanzó
respecto a la revisión de el desmontaje
de un sistema estructurado de corrupción
montado desde el estado en los 10 años
del correísmo una fuerte intención de
venganza y sobre todo retomar las formas
de gobierno claro os parece digamos
parece abanderar y con los que parece
simpatizar lo que sólo espera el ecuador
y una oposición un país altamente
dividido entre una derecha que se
articula atrás del lazo y una izquierda
que ha sido acostada hostigada
perseguida durante los 10 años del
correísmo que ahora está más articulada
y más fortalecida por el retorno de
pachakutik con un candidato fuerte bueno
sofía y hablemos ahora del legado del
presidente de lenin moreno que debe
continuar y que no
bueno el legado del presidente de ley
moreno es en primera instancia tratar de
desmontar una estructura corrupta una
estructura altamente
perjudicial para el estado sí que dio al
traste con la oportunidad de salir y
salir de algunos de algunas marcas
algunas marcas históricas del país con
los 10 años de bonanza sin embargo no se
hizo
lenin moreno sin embargo se aplazó se
aplazó en desmontar de verdad lo que fue
el régimen digamos de estructura
correísta quedaron muchos muchos legados
todavía y se aplazó sobre todo en la
ejecución la ejecución de nuevas
políticas la activación de un nuevo
gobierno que dé esperanza para marcar un
nuevo camino entonces yo creo que por
eso por eso nos encontramos en la
disyuntiva hoy de un retorno bastante
grave para el país sin haber logrado
generar un camino nuevo
sofía gracias por su análisis vamos a
cambiar de tema y en noticias de la
india una avalancha masiva se produjo en
el norte del país en el estado de
uttarakhand hay al menos 150
desaparecidos y ya se confirmaron tres
muertes un glaciar del himalaya se
rompió y se estrelló contra una presa
provocando inundaciones que obligaron a
evacuar las aldeas de arriba abajo
destruidas bajo una pared de polvo rocas
y agua el primer ministro- narendra modi
dijo que estaban siguiendo de cerca la
situación al tiempo que se movilizan
trabajadores de rescate
estoy monitoreando constantemente la
desafortunada situación en huracán india
apoya out arakan y la nación reza por la
seguridad de todos allí he estado
hablando continuamente con las máximas
autoridades y recibiendo actualizaciones
sobre el despliegue de la fuerza
nacional de respuesta a desastres el
trabajo de rescate y las operaciones de
socorro en mi animal por segundo día
consecutivo miles de personas salieron a
las calles de rangún es de la antigua
capital del país para exigir al ejército
que tomó el poder en golpe de estado el
primero de febrero el regreso de la
democracia y la liberación de las
personas detenidas incluyendo a la nobel
de paz y después está el líder del
gobierno democrático a un samsung chip
el operador más importante del país
anunció el regreso del internet
permitido por la junta militar veamos el
informe
las calles de rangún vuelven a pintarse
de rojo este domingo manifestantes
abanderando el color de la liga nacional
para la democracia el partido de la
nobel de paz encarcelada aung san suu
kyi salieron desde varios puntos de la
ciudad hasta concentrarse cerca de la
pagoda azul el monumento más
representativo del país
[Aplausos]
decidí resistir a la dictadura militar
en 2021 para no tener que vivir como en
ya hemos tomado una decisión vamos a
luchar hasta el final con nuestras vidas
por nuestra generación tenemos que
trabajar por la próxima generación para
conseguir la democracia para ellos si
queremos acabar con esa dictadura
militar
desde el golpe militar del lunes primero
de febrero al menos 152 personas
continúan detenidas entre ellas dos
sentenciados a dos años de cárcel por
cargos que no han sido precisados
mientras que las autoridades han dejado
en libertad a otras doce personas que
habían sido detenidas durante el golpe
mientras tanto el país recuperó al menos
temporalmente la conducción e internet
de este domingo bloqueada durante más de
24 horas por el gobierno militar los
servicios de internet de telenor ya se
han restablecido en mi amar
y aunque sigue vigente la censura
ordenada por los uniformados contra
twitter y facebook muchos usuarios
logran burlar las restricciones a través
de redes privadas virtuales en brasilia
del sambódromo de río de janeiro abrió
sus puertas pero esta vez para
convertirse en un centro de vacunación
no contra kobe 19 el lugar donde cada
año se celebra el carnaval más famoso
del mundo y que hoy debería estar
preparándose para la celebración acoge a
adultos mayores hay que reciben el
antídoto contra el virus
el lugar por donde han desfilado
despampanantes carrozas hoy sólo
transitan los vehículos de quienes
buscan protegerse del cob y 19 el
sambódromo de río de janeiro debía estar
preparándose para la celebración del
carnaval pero hoy está convertido en un
centro de vacunación y agua y si hablo
samboal estamos abriendo el sambódromo
para vacunar a las personas de forma
organizada sin agitación gente que
podría tener problemas para moverse por
tener más de 90 años por lo que están
siendo vacunadas dentro de su automóvil
vea todo propio como el carnaval de río
se había aplazado para mitades de año
pero por primera vez en un siglo uno de
los eventos más famosos del mundo no se
llevará a cabo el objetivo es seguir
evitando aglomeraciones mientras brasil
lucha contra un virus que ha cobrado la
vida de más de 230.000 personas la
segunda peor cifra a nivel global cada
año este es un lugar de júbilo para
miles de brasileños y visitantes
extranjeros pero hoy también lo es para
aquellos que confían en la campaña de
vacunación que me recibieron muy bien
estoy muy feliz muy satisfecha hasta me
dan ganas de llorar
he esperado tanto este momento que es
una buena sensación saber que ella
estará protegida no ahora sino con la
segunda dosis
brasil inició su jornada de inmunización
a mitades de enero y además de comprar
el país también ya está produciendo
dosis de las inyecciones de la empresa
china sinovac y de la británica
astrazéneca con el fin de vacunar a sus
210 millones de habitantes llegaron a
españa italia y francia- los primeros
lotes de vacunas astrazéneca contra kobe
y 19 en el caso español tras aprobarse
su uso el viernes se hizo un envío de
casi 200.000 dosis para acelerar la
campaña de inoculación en cursos en el
país asimismo en italia 250.000
inyecciones arribaron a un aeropuerto
militar al sur de roma y en francia el
medicamento empezó a ser distribuido
este fin de semana en lyon a un grupo de
trabajadores del sector salud en una
acción contra la criticada lentitud del
gobierno para el plan de inmunización
en plena crisis por kobe 19 la idea de
desarrollar un pasaporte de vacunas está
ganando terreno en varios países aunque
algunos argumentan que atenta contra los
derechos humanos otros consideran que es
la única forma de salir de la crisis
algunos países de europa ya lo han
probado y francia está debatiendo si
hacer lo mismo o no
un pasaporte de vacunación en el
teléfono parece un futuro distópico pero
pronto será una realidad en dinamarca
los daneses tendrán que mostrar los
suyos para ir al teatro al cine o para
salir a comer en europa
islandia ya ha comenzado a emitir
certificados y suecia dice que hará lo
mismo reino unido lo está pensando y
grecia defiende que impulsaría el
turismo en francia la opinión está
dividida si se publica ver si eso
significa que la gente puede volver a
ser libre para aquellos que quieren la
vacuna creo que es una gran idea en la
música pop yo estoy en contra es
inequitativo que anthony eso
el pasaporte les permitiría reabrir a
muchos bares y restaurantes y
tranquilizaría a los clientes
la mayoría de gente me dice que si los
restaurantes volvieran a abrir no se
sentirían cómodos sin un pasaporte de
vacunas esto no significaría estar en un
área cerrada con personas que no conocen
están preocupados pero la mayoría de los
centros culturales están en contra de la
idea
que abriríamos lo que significa que el
apoyo estatal terminaría pero no
tendríamos clientes ya que muy pocas
personas han recibido la vacuna por lo
que casi nadie podría ir al cine o de
compras no es viable y es muy
preocupante si se estresan quito el
pasaporte también plantearía un enigma
legal por los temores de que pudiera
infringir las libertades civiles básicas
no tienen que estar vacunado pero si
quieres ir a un restaurante al cine o
visitar un museo hay que vacunarse
entonces es tan bueno como obligatorio
el gobierno no ha descartado
definitivamente el pasaporte de vacunas
pero asegura que es demasiado pronto
para decidir
fin del informativo siga con nosotros
[Música]